our next speaker is going to talk about
anti-aging he is a researcher and a
future author on that topic his first
long now event was eight years ago
please welcome out chris patil
suppose i told you i have in my hand a
pill that will delay the rate of aging
and extend human longevity you would
probably have a few questions
where did it come from how do we know it
works maybe how can i get some
but
more importantly what are the
ramifications
how does the existence of a medication
like this change the way we think about
the future
soon a drug like this will be not
science fiction but science fact we're
entering the era of anti-aging medicine
this is a field in which i worked for
many years today i'd like to tell you
about it
um the first clinical trial of an
anti-aging medication is starting this
year metformin a drug that's been used
for decades to treat diabetes is being
tested to see if it can reduce the rate
of onset of age-related disease
aging itself isn't recognized as a
disease yet but it's the primary risk
factor for a very very large number of
unpleasant conditions as the graph on
the next slide will show
we know a great deal more about the
fundamental biology of aging than we did
just a few years ago when seminal work
at
mit and right here in san francisco
showed us that we can meaningfully study
aging in smaller shorter lived organisms
this early work showed us that
single gene mutations can actually
extend longevity in animals and soon we
learned that the same genes that control
aging in yeast and worms and flies
are conserved in mammals including human
beings
the discovery of conserved anti-aging
genes has some very deep implications
first it means that we can meaningfully
study aging in ourselves
by studying shorter lived animals and
this dramatically increases the rate of
research progress
second and more importantly
it means that aging itself is a process
that can be intervened in using drugs
and soon researchers found molecules
that can do exactly that
these drugs of which there are now many
known all work in different ways as they
must because aging isn't one thing but
many things happening at the same time
and in this sense the biology of aging
is like that old story about the seven
blind sages all trying to understand an
elephant by only touching one part of it
at a time
fortunately these drugs all have similar
effects on the lifespan curve which is
basically your chance of remaining alive
as a function of time in graph form they
all push the curve to the right which
means they extend the health span which
is what we call the healthy part of
adult life and that's a good thing
because we want people to be living
longer not just dying longer
but how do we convince the fda or other
regulatory bodies that a given
medication is safe and effective
this is especially challenging humans
because human beings are terrible
experimental animals we're what a
scientist might call poorly controlled
we eat badly and differently we exercise
irregularly or not at all how do we get
human beings to sit still and behave
long enough that we can measure the
effect of a drug on an 80-year lifespan
the simple answer of course is that we
don't do it that way instead we look at
shorter term endpoints in the metformin
study i mentioned earlier the idea is
that
aging is the primary risk factor for a
lot of different diseases so if a drug
delays the onset of many different
diseases over a few years it's probably
acting by delaying the underlying rate
of aging
an alternative is that we could develop
what are called biomarkers which are
cellular and molecular signatures that
track along with the rate of
chronological aging and allow us to
measure aging in real time
you might be ready to go now
you might have heard enough you might
think well if the medication is
ineffective and i take it nothing bad
happens probably but if the
medicine is
effective and i wait to take it i might
be robbing myself of years of productive
life
unfortunately you're out of luck unless
you happen to be a dog
there's a multi-center team that's
testing another drug called rapamycin to
see whether or not it can extend
lifespan in dogs the same way we know it
does in mice
the early findings have been very very
promising and assuming funding exists
the team hopes to expand the study to
thousands of dogs in the next few years
we're not going to know whether these
medications work in humans for a while
yet but
many many compounds are known to exist
and many many more on the way
several companies and research
institutions have been founded some of
them very nearby
to develop new medications test them and
then translate these findings into the
clinic
so eventually we will have an anti-aging
pharmacopia and everyone in this room is
going to have to ask themselves
should i take advantage of it i'm not
talking about 10 000 year life spans
here but i am talking about a world in
which many of us will be around for
decades longer than we are now and we'll
be forced to confront the consequences
of our own actions in a way that we
aren't necessarily today
so what happens when we all live longer
do we overpopulate the planet
or are longer-lived people better
stewards of the environment
will societies and institutions benefit
from the preservation of knowledge
that's currently lost to senescence and
death
extending lifespan has personal societal
and planetary implications and i'd
submit to you that it's something that
those of us with a long-term perspective
should start thinking about
now
you